we begin with President Trump who's
holding a campaign style rally in
Michigan today but he teased something
dramatic could happen when he meets with
North Korean leader Kim jong-un the
Trump administration hopes that meeting
will take place in the coming weeks
sources tell CBS News Mongolia and
Singapore are the two final countries
under consideration for the historic
summit hours before the president spoke
kim jeong-hoon across that border into
South Korea he was greeted by South
Korean president moon jae-in president
Trump said after a furious year of
missile launches and nuclear testing
good things are happening
Errol Barnett is at the White House Erol
good morning good morning president
Trump said in the past the US has been
played like a fiddle when negotiating
with North Korea now though president
Trump says kim jeong-hoon isn't playing
games this time around and if there is
no agreement to be made he says he'll
just leave the room this should not have
been left for me to handle president
Trump said bringing peace to the Korean
Peninsula is his responsibility we will
not repeat the mistake of past
administration's blaming predecessors
for failing to halt North Korea's
nuclear development maximum pressure
will continue until denuclearization
occurs the president said he was
encouraged by Kim Jong Un's goal of
denuclearization and recognized American
allies China Japan and Germany for
helping administrations max pressure
efforts hours before President Trump's
comments Kim Jong Un's shook hands and
embraced South Korean president moon
jae-in the first time in 65 years in
North Korean leader walked south of the
border I also want to congratulate the
Republic of Korea and North Korea on the
historic meeting newly confirmed
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo who met
with Kim earlier this month
said the US wants North Korea's weapons
dismantled we would not be where we are
today without president Trump's maximum
pressure campaign pompei Oh was in
Brussels for meetings with NATO members
just 24 hours after the Senate of
proved his nomination the nomination is
confirmed the former CIA director will
also travel to Saudi Arabia Jerusalem
and Jordan to discuss the Iran nuclear
deal
is unlikely to stay in that deal
president Trump discussed Iran with the
French president and German Chancellor
both of whom visited the White House
this week to convince mr. Trump to stay
in the agreement the president declined
to say whether military force would be
an option if he is unable to negotiate a
new arrangement but made one thing clear
they're not gonna be doing nuclear
weapons you can bank on it now next
month president Trump will need to
decide on if he will continue to suspend
sanctions on Iran they were initially
lifted under the 2015 agreement and next
week there's another big foreign policy
decision for the president a decision on
whether to continue to allow the EU to
be exempt from the steel and aluminium
tariffs Michelle big decision there
Errol Barnett at the White House thank
you